okay so first of all you look so cozy so
comfy
where are you right now i am
on the floor in my closet
i can honestly say this is the first
time i've interviewed somebody on the
floor so congratulations
well and that's what you get when you
interview me
yeah i love it i have to tell you
how good you were on snl i mean that's a
dream come
true for any artist to perform on that
show but you shared the stage
with miley cyrus guest host elon musk i
mean
what was the energy like in that studio
well um i it was it was crazy
i saw a couple comments online and
people were like
yo this is the most random link up ever
and i would have to agree i would say
like it was it was pretty cool though it
was it was
very random but very cool i mean you
know miley she's great um
elon he's obviously great um and they're
both great people in in real life um
yeah
elon i got to chat to elon at the at
like the after party like properly like
um
we had like a little chat on the set but
it was kind of like hectic so then like
at the after party
we're at like this like club type of
thing and um
there's like lots of loud music playing
in the background and stuff
and uh i walk up to him like oh elon
what's up
he's like oh hey man what's up and i was
like
so i need to ask you a question he was
like okay
and i said um if you're me you're a
young artist
who's like making some money and like i
want to spend my money
where do i where do i spend it and where
do i put it at
and he uh and he goes and he like thinks
for like 15 seconds and he's like
put in something that you love and i was
like oh
i was like really he was like yeah he's
like you know and you know because i
i'm kind of like i was kind of like
expecting him to like
give me a whole breakdown but it was
actually very smart what he said
he said uh he said make sure you invest
your money but make sure you're invested
in a product that you love
and that uh and that you're a fan of
because if you're not a fan of it then
like why would anybody else be a fan of
it pretty much so
hey listen that's some pretty sound
advice from elon musk that's pretty cool
pretty good yeah yeah pretty awesome
um did your family freak out to see you
perform at snl
how supportive are they yeah they were
they were they were loving it they were
like
like crying
that's so cool um so look me just like
everybody else
i love without um i i just love this
song
so much how did miley end up on the
track without you
so pretty much what happened was um
my boy omar who produced the song
um pretty much what happened was like i
guess he was working with miley as well
like he had just started working with
miley and then like they were in the
studio one day
and like i guess it came on the
the tv while they were in the studio my
performance on jimmy fallon
and um and they were watching it
together and he was like oh yeah that's
my boy and this is a song like that
and she was like oh sick this is sick
i guess and then i i don't know how it
exactly happened but one way or another
he came to me and he was like yo she
wants to do the remix are you down and i
was like yeah i'm down let's do it
so then we did it yeah that's so cool
what was it like working with her in
studio
um it was it was sick she's uh she's
cool
and she's like she's she's super open to
like just like
and she just wants to like get right and
get it perfect and get it done and
and get it to the best it can be so yeah
i always love i always love people like
that i always love people who
who want to walk and get the best music
and not necessarily just be like oh
like i'm doing it this way or that it's
like i love i love like collaborative
processes and
and she was great so i love hearing that
you posted this awesome photo
with you and miley in studio and in the
caption you just repeated hannah montana
several times
is it fair to say you were a fan of the
series
uh yeah you know i was uh
i used to watch it with my
cousin my cousin who was
yeah she was uh she used to make me
watch that
so but buddy it was a great show by the
way i got a
book i just said it like like it was
like whatever like oh yeah i didn't like
the show i
loved it i got hooked it was great um
and then obviously but the the cat
the caption was referring to a song by
the migos
oh nice nice so how did your cousins
how did your cousin react when she found
out that you're actually working with
hannah montana
i don't know i i haven't spoke to her in
yet
okay all right we don't speak anymore
that's amazing um you know i understand
that the original version
of without you appeared on your debut
album last year
um what did you want to say with that
album
um i wanted to just tell my story
really that's all it was i just wanted
to like i don't know with all the music
i make it all comes off
of like real life and like real phases
of my life and i guess uh that's what it
was like
it went from like love and then they
went to like savage because i'm like
okay now i'm in like savage mode
you know so i guess that's what it was
it was just like i don't know i think my
thing is like an artist is like
i just want to like you know my job is
to just be completely honest
on in my music and put it out how it is
and like
hopefully other people can relate to it
and like if not
well i guess you know it's me
so what mode would you say you're in now
um i would right now i'm an album
in album mode actually yeah so you're
working on new music
yeah i am is it going to be similar
is there anything you can tease us about
this sound or is it completely different
um you guys are just gonna have to wait
and see such a tease no no that's good i
know you can't say much
you know you have had so much so much
success i mean i know you've been
working on music for a while now
who would you say has been your biggest
cheerleader throughout this
whole journey of yours my mom
yeah my mom my mom is always my biggest
supporter
did she know that you always wanted to
get into music like when you were a kid
yeah oh yeah of course yeah i always i
always tell my mom
my mom used to like my mom used to like
stay up late at night like
trying to go through like internet forms
and like try and find like
numbers for like young money and back in
the day it's funny
ah she just must be so proud of you
right now
yeah i hope so no she is
okay so you worked with miley that's
like a bucket list you know
check who else would you love to
collaborate with
um kaiye oh drake
those would be awesome have you had
other artists reach out to you since
you've performed on late night and of
course on snl
uh what can you tell me
well well i can't tell you but what i
can say
is yes oh cause i can't tell you
that yeah well because you know they say
if i tell you i have to kill you so
yeah okay so i don't want that to happen
so
keep your secrets just like everybody
else
that's hilarious um you know so much has
happened to you it
do you think like down the road like
five even ten years down the road
where you'd love to be in this industry
or just in your life
my life and and ten years down
yeah i would uh i would love to be
happy
hey that's so important i would just
love to be happy
that's all yeah yeah and you'd still
love to be doing music
yeah of course um you know i'm sure your
mom has given you amazing advice but has
there been an artist out there
that has given you a piece of advice
that you still
listen to to this day and if it's from
your mom that's great too
yeah um justin
justin always gives me great advice like
i i don't know
it's cool because like with justin i
feel like i can literally like just call
that dude like and ask him anything and
he's always like super
you know down to to to listen and
and give me advice which i think is
really cool because i think like
like someone like him he's like been
through like everything
when it comes to so like you know i
think that's cool but yeah
there's a great piece of advice you gave
me which was one day i was on the way to
a photo shoot
and um we were on facetime and he was
like oh what are you doing today
and i said oh um i'm on my way
to this photo shoot right
and uh and i was like oh but you know i
don't i don't
you know i'm like i don't know i was
like oh i'm tired like i don't really
want to do it
and he was like yo dude he's like
just he's like take it all in for a
minute and just realize like how lucky
you are to be doing that he's like even
like
he's like i know stuff gets annoying and
stuff gets like under your skin
on your nose but he's like think about
how lucky you are to do this like you're
from
sydney australia i'm from somewhere in
canada
and like this is our dream like you're
literally living your dream so like just
like be grateful and like take it in and
like
and just be nice to everyone and uh and
and yeah
i don't know i thought that was like i
thought that was great advice i was like
yo you know what that's right like
there's a lot of other work i could be
doing right now
yeah how did your relationship with
justin bieber bieberster
well he uh he dm me on instagram and he
said uh he said you got the sauce
and uh and i was like all right sick and
then um
i was like oh hey man big fan
and then and then he just liked my
message and i was like all right cool
then like a month later he messaged me
he's like yo what's your number i think
i have the song for us to do
and then he like uh and then yeah he
like
i was like in the shower when i texted
him my number and i was like oh
i hope he doesn't call me while i'm in
the shower and he like called me and i
was in the shower and i like had to pick
up and i was like hey man i'm getting
out of the shower
and he was just and he was just like
you're hilarious so yeah
that is so cool and especially justin
has been through so much at such a young
age just like yourself
uh that must feel pretty good to have
somebody like him that you can call
and rely on to give you good advice yeah
it feels great